Curious to know which Home Improvement guest
star was also in Back to the Future?
And did you know that one of the show's recurring
characters co-founded the L.A. improv troupe
The Groundlings?
Keep watching to find out more.
When Tim and his family sought advice or needed
to vent, they often went into their backyard
and talked things over with their plainspoken
neighbor Wilson W. Wilson, played by Earl
Hindman.
The character was based on Tim Allen's childhood
neighbor, whose face was hidden because Allen
was too short to see him completely.
Wilson was forever obscured by a fence and
a hat, which was the show's long-running gag
that grew even more complicated and humorous
as they let him out of the house and into
the world more often.
After appearing in almost every episode, Wilson's
face was finally revealed to the audience
in the series finale curtain call.
Hindman's face started to get recognized back
in the '70s, with supporting roles in films
like The Parallax View and The Taking of Pelham
One Two Three.
Outside of Home Improvement, his most well-known
role was detective Bob Reid on the soap opera
Ryan's Hope.
Fittingly, his final contribution to television
was lending his voice as the narrator of the
Tim Allen Presents: A User's Guide to Home
Improvement retrospective from 2003.
That same year, Hindman died of lung cancer
at the age of 61.
In early 2021, Tim Allen paid tribute to Wilson
on his other hit sitcom Last Man Standing,
where his newer character Mike Baxter meets
his older one, Tim Taylor.
"It's easier to open up when I'm just talking
to the top half of another man's face."
In a kill or be killed type profession, drummer-turned-actor
Mickey Jones estimated in 2009 that he had
killed 137 people and had been killed 92 times
— on screens big and small, that is.
In one of his numerous roles, he was killing
it in a humorous sort of way; on Home Improvement,
he played K&B Construction worker Pete Bilker
for 13 episodes.
Pete rocked out with Tim and the "Tool Time"
gang, cooking and drinking up a storm in honor
of St. Patrick and the Super Bowl, and playing
in a band using tools as instruments.
"Let’s roll!"
"Beat!"
"That would be me."
He once even watched Tim fall into a port-a-John
on a job site.
Talk about your potty humor!
Jones' entertainment business journey began
on the music side as a drummer for Trini Lopez,
then for Johnny Rivers, where he provided
the backing beat to the hit "Secret Agent Man."
Next, he replaced Levon Helm behind the kit
and toured with Bob Dylan on his landmark
1966 world tour.
Jones was also a founding member of the rock
group the First Edition with Kenny Rogers.
An apparent Forrest Gump of the entertainment
industry for multiple decades, he seemed to
be everywhere, including an appearance in
the gatefold photo standing behind The Eagles
inside the "Hotel California" LP.
In speaking about his change of mediums, Jones
had this to say:
"I had always dreamed of being an actor, so
I went for it."
He went on to find roles as bearded tough
guys, bikers, and nice bearded guys who sometimes
ride bikes in flicks like National Lampoon's
Vacation and Sling Blade.
Later on in his career, Jones appeared as
a series regular on the FX crime drama Justified.
He died at the age of 76 in 2018.
Tim's buddy Harry owned a hardware store where
Mr. Tool Time liked to enjoy his off time.
However, it's not usually fun when Harry's
wife Delores is around to bust his chops,
argue with him over everything, and give him
"The Look."
Delores was played by comedian Shirley Prestia,
and the role ended up being one of the biggest
of her career.
A memorable episode finds her working at the
store and driving everyone insane.
This leads to Tim giving Harry bad advice
that, in turn, nearly dissolves his marriage.
However, Tim realizes he's done wrong, so
he works to fix that, making the title of
the episode ring true: "When Harry Kept Dolores."
Prestia was one of the founding members of
the Los Angeles-based improv and sketch comedy
team The Groundlings in the 1970s.
It was during her time at The Groundlings
that she yukked it up on stage alongside legends
such as Paul Ruebens, Phil Hartman, and Laraine
Newman.
She went on to a steady career of guest-starring
and bit parts in sitcoms such as Cheers, and
films like Wag The Dog.
After an 8 year battle with brain cancer,
Prestia died in 2011 at the age of 64.
The titular "Ye Olde Shoppe Teacher" that
inspired a young Timothy Taylor to a life
of "more power" pays his prized pupil a visit
three times in consecutive seasons.
Portrayed by Dick O'Neill, Art Leonard first
arrives as a shell of his former self who
is unable to operate heavy machinery due to
his arthritis.
Next, in the episode titled "That's My Momma,"
he made wanted advances on Tim's mom, which
were unwanted by the son.
Things got even stranger when Tim caught Mr.
Leonard "shopping around" with another woman.
The “Tool Man” then confronted his teacher
about it, saying:
"So, one hammer's not good enough for you?"
But, all ended well with some kissing and
making up.
Straight-talking men of authority with a tinge
of a smile were the types of characters O'Neill
excelled at playing.
He served the public portraying fictional
policemen, detectives, army personnel, commissioners,
wardens, and judges in a wide range of shows
like Barney Miller, Diff'rent Strokes, and
Family Matters.
Additionally, O'Neil played Sharon Gless'
pops on 26 episodes of Cagney & Lacey.
Never usually the star, he supported others
well, as he did with carnival barker Steve
Martin in The Jerk, Jack Nicholson in Prizzi's
Honor, and Harrison Ford in The Mosquito Coast.
He even tangled with Earl Hindman before in
The Taking of Pelham One Two Three as subway
dispatcher Frank Correll.
O'Neill died of heart failure in 1998 at the
age of 70.
Master plumber Felix Myman was a key figure
for six episodes of Home Improvement, showing
up at the Taylor household for all of the
family's plumbing disasters.
He once even got in the crossfire of a caulking
gun battle between Tim and Al on "Tool Time."
Felix was played by Al Fann, a productive
actor and student of theater who even founded
his own namesake Theatrical Ensemble to train
and develop aspiring young stage actors.
Fann's professional breakthrough came in 1953
on The Bob Hope Network Television Show and
wrapped up in the Coen Brothers 2004 remake
of The Ladykillers.
In between, he popped up in Good Times, The
Jeffersons, Happy Days, and Curb Your Enthusiasm.
Al Fann passed away in 2018 at the age of
93.
Tom Poston is perhaps one of the most prolific
comedic actors to appear on TV sitcoms, so
it's no shock that his resume included ratcheting
it up on Home Improvement three different times.
He first showed up as a multi-hyphenated desk
clerk named Fred trying to “help” a snowed-in
Tim and Al get home in "'Twas The Night Before
Christmas."
The next season, he played Fred's brother
Ned, a "helpful" auto shop owner who allows
it to become a delivery room in "The Tool
Man Delivers."
Fred and Ned's brother Ted is the Taylors’
personal guide at the annual Detroit Lions
Thanksgiving day game, although this time
around, it's Tim who is of no "help," as he
knocks out the stadium's electricity.
Steve Allen, Don Knotts, Bob Newhart, Tim
Conway — these are among the revered comedy
legends that worked with and greatly respected
Poston.
However, he may not be as appreciated as many
of his contemporaries were.
His career thrived on supporting work and
his television resume read like a what's what
of sitcom history, with roles in Get Smart,
Newhart, Murphy Brown, and Will & Grace.
While not a giant film actor, he did make
some appearances on the big screen, including
spending another Christmastime with Tim Allen
in 2004's Christmas with the Cranks.
Poston passed on in 2007 at the age of 85.
Ann Morgan Guilbert was only 14 years older
than Earl Hindman when she showed up to play
the woman who brought Wilson Jr. into the
world for the Mother's Day-themed episode
"To Build or Not to Build."
"Sure is good to meet you.
Whoa!
I see where Wilson gets his good looks."
Wilson flew her in from the Yukon and the
two were excited to celebrate in Greektown,
but before they headed out, they imparted
wisdom and motherly gift ideas to Tim on behalf
of his boys.
A "D" grade in Chemistry at Stanford led this
nursing student to switch majors to speech
and drama, which subsequently launched Guilbert's
long acting career.
Her first big role was playing neighbor Millie
Helper on The Dick Van Dyke Show.
She also played Nora for ten episodes on The
New Andy Griffith Show, talked fresh produce
with Burgess Meredith in Grumpier Old Men,
and guest-starred on both Seinfeld and Curb
Your Enthusiasm.
Guilbert also portrayed a grandmother on The
Nanny and in the 2010 film Please Give.
She acted up until 2016 when she died of cancer
at age 87.
A mother herself, she is survived by two daughters,
including actress Hallie Todd, who played
the mother on Lizzie McGuire.
As the clock started to run out on Home Improvement,
things got a bit corrosive and explosive in
the show's three-part finale "The Long and
Winding Road."
In the episode, a new producer of "Tool Time”
wants to spice things up by putting the tools
down and doing a talk-only program.
But what he actually does is stage a Jerry
Springer-like three-ring circus.
During the segment, a character named Sue
claims she has been cheating on her husband,
which leads to an on-set brawl.
Brassy-mouthed Sue, played with high intensity
by Wendie Jo Sperber, came out swinging and
ended up kicking Tim in the chin.
The ratings stunt left Tim furious and questioning
whether to go on with the show.
Sperber broke into Hollywood as a scene-stealer
right off the bat in Robert Zemeckis' 1978
Beatlemania pic I Wanna Hold Your Hand.
She would reteam with Zemeckis and join Steven
Spielberg for 1941 and the first and third
installments of Back To The Future, where
she notably played Marty McFly's disinterested
sister Linda.
Sperber also collaborated with Tom Hanks on
the TV show Bosom Buddies and joined him again
two years later in Bachelor Party.
Sadly, she died of breast cancer in 2005 at
the age of 47.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.